b
was geht absolut ruhig auf die hatte
bisher wunderschönen tag das intro ja
das ist ein bisschen komisch falls ihr
den letzten job gesehen haben solltet es
dir dass ich am ende zu einem kollegen
von mir gefahren aus der uni der seinen
geburtstag gefeiert in holte bei dem man
kennen muss ich glaube ich verstehen
alle da ist wenn ich bei ihm halt
schlafe bei seiner familie und so dass
wir nicht an morgen sie das typische
glocken zu machen dass es ein bisschen
in der prob radiation gerade deswegen
ein bisschen bescheid zum film mit den
nicht verhältnis von uns heute sagen wir
sehen und zu hause wieder natürlich
gestern aufgefallen ist ein kumpel von
mir heute von wald wird nach köln weil
wir das wochenende trennen wollte
dann landet genau in zehn minuten nein
ich stehe noch ein frisches geld für
technisch nationalist an einer
jogginghose und ihs
altair abendessen nicht ich bin schon
echt zu spät und meinen kollegen
abzuholen aber der hat ja auch noch ein
bisschen verspätung
ich habe mit ihm telefoniert aber dann
kommt eine polizeikontrolle
polizeikontrolle wir vorne auch wieder
irgendwelche kontrollen alter was geht
ab restlos ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
ob gerade irgend ein hochrangiger
politiker oder so in köln oder in star
oder im konzert oder eine warnung ist
von der bombe waren keine ahnung man
vermutet er mir das schlimmste aber was
ich musste nicht putzt oder irgendwas
aber immerhin der führerschein dem
fahrzeug haben ihre bitte um ich geb dir
natürlich von den fahrzeugschein von
einem alten mini oper gemacht und auf
jeden fall auf jeden fall habe ich den
dann hat in diesem fahrzeug leihvertrag
gegeben den ich halt von porsche
bekommen habe im rahmen dieser
kooperation jetzt und da habe ich
einfach nicht vorgeschrieben da stehen
auch keine anderen daten von mir drauf
also die waren so ein bisschen skeptisch
und dann habe ich den halter aber
einfach mal alles erklärt abwägen sagt
hey ich bin lieber ich hab diese karte
hier von porsche bekommen und bin jetzt
hier bei zum carrera cup bin ich jetzt
morgen und blabla davon die dann auch
verstanden ich höre jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal finden hab ich mal vernünftige
musik war immer hier singen louis und
dann toyota carina fahren konnte ich
auch produziert wird er ist der grösste
vollidiot der welt und hat ein handy im
auto liegenlassen aber findet er und er
holt er läuft den kleinen pilze eine
ganz kurze sache und zwar seht ihr ja
schon dass ich eigentlich immer wenn ich
mir essen bestellen bei verloren stelle
das halt in den blogs gesehen und meint
dann luca hast nicht doch irgendwie
jeder ein zuschauer wurde freude zu
machen deswegen könnt diesen code
einlösen dann kommt ihr gewissen betrag
war sie als gutschein erstattet bei
einer bestellung
ich bin ja auch locker was hältst du vom
besten bürger zu stings ist mit der
besten kumpels nach düsseldorf wie ihr
vielleicht wisst fand ich jetzt gerade
ein 911 carrera gts heckantrieb und ich
habe im regen so ein bisschen probleme
aquaplaning und jetzt viel weiter vorne
forciert gerade das ist gerade das
zweite mal dass ich den weg laufen
öffentlichen straßen
das zweite mal
luca wollen wir nicht eigentlich
düsseldorf fahren ja einfach seit einer
stunde den gt3 an diesem auto am besten
liefen der fahrer
der gt3 ist verboten die karte ist halt
doch noch mal ein bisschen krasser daran
jetzt ist auf jeden fall dass wir weiter
truppen kürbissen alle leute die keine
ahnung haben dass ich nicht dafür
interessieren denken wir waren jetzt
große kleinigkeit was training in der
minibar von funktioniere und fahren
jetzt nach zu mir nach hause kurzweilig
und dann nach düsseldorf wie carola
wiedersehen werde
ich hab echt nicht geschwitzt nicht
weise war heute sagen die 16 grad oder
so aber weil diese karte
das war sex pur wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste zwischen der nacht
mit alex reid und dieser kann dann bin
ich wahrscheinlich schon krank wie
gesagt hol ich mir okay ich ziehe jetzt
eben was anderes an und danach fahren
wir nach düsseldorf
düsseldorf angekommen und dahin besteht
da steht einer hier vorne stehen noch
zwei düsseldorfer bei euch läuft wir
gehen jetzt auf jeden fall statt ich
nehme die kamera allerdings nicht mit
den ersten auftritten mit dem handy
gemacht sein
warum
die freude dann steht man ganz normal in
düsseldorf so noch einmal
meine damen und herren das ist gerade 10
uhr wir haben bei einer freundin in
düsseldorf geschlafen hat und nicht weil
wir hier einfach spontan hingefahren
sind gestern haben auf jeden fall
verliert der parcours zurück nach köln
haben weil wir jetzt duschen gehen
werden das war konsens aktion ist in
düsseldorf hingegen sind weil es war
irgendwie zurück gurken nach köln
übernachten einfach in düsseldorf und
dann nochmal danke paulina für die
herberge wir sind jetzt hier im versand
und wollten wer jetzt im nürburgring
fahren habe ich auf jeden fall hat bock
drauf das ist ja die ganze sache
deswegen ich auch die post bekommen
hatte bei wieder zum carrera cup fahren
werden bis halb richtig
ich mache jetzt auf jeden fall kommen
zwei hinter mir sitzen jetzt im auto
fahren jetzt zum nürburgring und leute
ich habe bock
also
so
mafffin wie war es so im regen zu pes
angekommen tschüss baby wir sehen uns
daher wieder
wir laufen jetzt ja das ist unser
beauftragter des automobilherstellers
porsche
wie heißt er denn auf instagram laser
lukas hat porsche wieder richtig wieder
am start davon übrigens im turbo s
freunde und diesen hintern alter
jetzt lasten vor der brust
leute
da fahren eben gerade keine porsche
waren herdecker wir glaube ich davon
nicht gerade eine wende zum positiven
und sogar
das alles schön reden sie mit
liga
alle am regenschirm aus haben wir auf
dieses konto
da eigentlich davon
es geht aber der abschluss scheint
irgendwie zu sein wir haben an meinem
auto
münster zu geben
jetzt ist das glaube ich schon
für die zeit zwischen der sony dsc der
film der kompaktkamera und erkennen und
80 d ich glaube mit der hier einfach
viel lieber natürlich die qualität der
anderen besser aber nicht
die fressen
[Musik]
dafür sind jetzt die ganzen gt3 cup s
noch schon die ganzen fahrer drinnen und
jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich schon
wieder von der strecke runter weil das
rennen losgeht
und zwar schnell
damit die schnell ab
foto wie möchtest du zu dem heutigen tag
immer sagen für namen schluss längst
aufgehört zu denken du hast auf jeden
fall ein schönes auto dabei
ein sehr schöner tag am nürburgring
meine damen und herren zu ende gegangen
es hat megageil viel spaß gewalt vor uns
fährt gerade noch tobi seinen kanal für
die in der beschreibung verlinkten
attacken der rauchen 911 carrera gts
werden das kabel hat das coupé haben das
heißt hier dürfte sogar noch ein
bisschen schneller sein würde ich sagen
ist einfach viel zu teilen
[Musik]
hallo dumm wäre wieder zu hause in
meiner wohnung angekommen was man denn
hier hat nicht gesehen
das fragt man dabei von dollar bestellt
bester laden wir auf jeden fall haben
wir jetzt hier die wievielte pakete für
drei leute ja das war es jetzt aber auch
hier vom blog meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen ist das getan
hat
wir waren heute wirklich den ganzen tag
am nürburgring hat auf jeden fall als
ultra spaß gemacht und ja wenn ihr noch
kein abonnent von meinem kanal seid
könnt ihr einfach unter dem video
abonnieren klicken und wenn dies aber
nicht sein glaubt klicken dann bekommt
die benachrichtigung sobald ich ein
neues video hochladen sonst würde ich
jetzt sagen sehen wir uns in einem
dienst wieder und zwar übermorgen am
dienstag in kiel
[Musik]